[संगीत]
ए
हेलो एवरीवन गुड इवनिंग एक बार आप लोग
सबसे पहले यह बता दीजिए की सबको मेरी आवाज
ए रही है नहीं ए रही सबसे पहले चाट में
फटाफट यह बता दीजिए की आप सबको मेरी आवाज
सुने दे दिया
थैंक यू
और थैंक यू पर डेट कितना सपोर्ट करने के
लिए और जो हमने आप लोगों से उम्मीद की थी
की आप लोग हमें बनकर करवा
[संगीत]
तो इसलिए कर दिया की आप लोगों ने काफी
कोशिश की है हमारे लिए और शेर किया है
तथा'एस वही आई की वन दे
हो जाना चाहिए तो आपको
हमने प्रॉमिस से पहले ही आपके लिए वीडियो
से दूर कर दिया है तो आप लोगों की
जिम्मेदारी बंटी है आप लोगों को क्या करना
है
बट मैं आप लोगों से एक उम्मीद कर सकता हूं
की मिनिमम जी पर हमने शेड्यूल किया है
क्योंकि अगर पता चला की दे तू की जो
वीडियो है अगर उसे पर मेरा 700 व्यू नहीं
होगा तो फिर तो बंता ही नहीं सेकंड थर्ड
वीडियो शेड्यूल करना मिनिमम इतना तो रहना
ही चाहिए की मेरी हर वीडियो को मिनिमम
सेवन हंड्रेड तो चाहिए क्योंकि मेरा जो
इफेक्ट है वो वैसे तो वन के प्लस का ही है
उससे भी ज्यादा मेरे पास मेरी वीवो आने
चाहिए बट फिर भी चलो
मुझे कुछ नहीं चाहिए आप लोगों से बस इतनी
ही रिक्वेस्ट है और अगर आप लोग लाइक करते
तो प्लीज कमेंट भी कर दिया है वह उसने दो
शब्द लिखने में कुछ फर्क नहीं पड़ता किसी
को भी बट हमें मोटिवेट मिलता है लेकिन
बस हमें थोड़ा मोटिवेट मिलते हैं अगर आगे
नेगेटिव कमेंट तो नेगेटिव भी चलेगा
फर्स्ट दे है जो फर्स्ट दे यहां पढ़ने के
लिए
मैंने बताया था की सेल क्या होता है बेस्ट
क्या होता है
और मैंने
बेस्ट स्किपिंग क्या होती है और स्ट्रक्चर
कैसी होती है गैस की और उसके जो कर
कॉम्पोनेंट्स कौन-कौन से होते हैं
तो यह चीज हमने लास्ट क्लास में डिस्कस
किया था जो काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है
उसमें जो पढ़ने वाला मां भी बता देता हूं
बट एक और चीज बता देता हूं की अगर किसी को
डाउट है तो मैं काम करूंगा
चाट की तरफ देखूंगा तो उससे प्रॉब्लम यह
होती है की मैं ग जाऊंगा तो फिर से
डाइवर्ट हो जाता हूं तो कंटिन्यू फॉक्स
करेंगे
कॉन्सेप्ट स्टार्ट होने वाले और काफी ही
इंपॉर्टेंट है अगर वह कॉन्सेप्ट
क्रिएट ए माल स्क्रिप्ट
लाइक प्रोफेशनल
स्क्रिप्ट होगी प्रोफेशनल की तरह कैसी
दिखती है कैसे हम क्रिएट कर सकते हैं उसके
बड़े में कुछ चिंता करने की जरूर नहीं है
की उसमें कुछ चीज मुझे समझ में नहीं की
इसका मतलब क्या है डोंट वारी जब और ऑफ डी
बेस्ट समझ में ए रहे होगी हां लेकिन उसमें
कुछ जो कमांडर्स की होगी अगर आपको नहीं
पता तो आप क्या काम कर सकते हो की जाके
मैं काली जिसकी प्ले रिस्पांस कमांड्स के
बड़े में सिख सकते हो हर चीज सबसे
इंपॉर्टेंट है जो मैं आपको बताने वाला हूं
बहुत ही ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है जो सबसे में
कॉन्सेप्ट है
जो हम आज से स्टार्ट करेंगे ही उसका छोटा
सा पार्ट स्टार्ट करने वाले हैं
आपके टॉपिक रहेंगे
आप लोग तीनों टॉपिक करेंगे जो मामलों यार
डिस्कस करने वाला हूं वन बाय वन
सबसे पहले कमेंटिंग के बड़े में यह
कमेंटिंग होती क्या है सबसे पहले मैं आपको
बताऊंगा कमेंटिंग होती है बिल्कुल आराम से
पढ़ेंगे
तो उनके लिए काफी जरूरी है आराम चीजों को
बताना तो सबसे पहले बताऊंगा
व्हाट इसे
रोमांटिक
रोमांटिक होती है जिसको हम बोलते हैं
कमेंट्स
जिसको हम बोलते हैं कमेंट
इसको हम बोलते हैं
ताकि आप लोगों को पता चल जाए
देखो
जनरल प्रोग्रामिंग
प्रोग्राम
युटुब
एड
वूमेन
टेलिंग
वूमेन कमेंट्स
तू
योर टिप्स
लिखने के लिए आगे कमेंट
लिखने हैं तो आपको पूरा प्रोग्राम हमेशा
याद नहीं राहत इस टाइम आप कोड लिख रहे
होते हैं उसे टाइम आपके दिमाग में एक
स्नायु के साथ कोड लिख रहे थे उसके बाद
कुछ टाइम के बाद में राहत नहीं है और
कहानी पर कुछ वैरियेबल्स उसे किया होंगे
आपने कहानी पर कुछ फंक्शंस उसे किया होंगे
कहानी पर कुछ आपने लॉजिक उसे किया होगा अब
आपके दिमाग में वो लॉजिक था उसे टाइम पर
ठीक है आपके पास अगर आपने अपने बुक्स में
नोट्स बनके उनके रखें हैं लाजिक्स का तो
वह
सही है आपके पास है बट हो सकता है की आपको
हमेशा बुक्स नहीं है लेकिन आप सिस्टम के
साथ जा रहे हो तो उसे टाइम पर आपके दिमाग
में लॉजिक था लेकिन बाद में वह दिमाग से
लॉजिक चला जाएगा लेकिन अगर आपने एक अच्छी
तरीके से कमेंटिंग कर राखी है आपकी बोर्ड
में लेकिन बेसिकली सिर्फ आपके लिए होती है
वह अगर आप
पब्लिश करते पब्लिकली तो वहां पर कमेंटिंग
हटा दी जाति है
जब आप क्या करते हो की जब आप कमेंटिंग
करते हो
ओ सॉरी मैं क्या था अपनी टॉपिक से थोड़ा
सा ध्यान
कमेंटिंग तो आप जब कमेंट क्यों करते हो
कमेंट इसलिए करते हो क्या की जो लॉजिक
आपने जो लगाया था वो लॉजिक आप वो अपने
ह्यूमन फॉर्म में या उसे टैक्स में आप
वहां पर मेंशन कर देते हो ताकि जब भी
नेक्स्ट टाइम आपको उसे कोड के साथ
मोडिफिकेशन करना हो या उसे कोड को रिवाइट
करना हो या कुछ भी उसमें चेंज करना हो तो
आप इजीली कर पाओगे दूसरा रीजन क्या है
कमेंट करने का दूसरा जान यह है की पर
एग्जांपल कोई भी थर्ड पार्टी है ये वाला
आपका टीम मेंबर्स है अब आप अवेलेबल नहीं
हो कोड अवेलेबल है और उसमें कुछ
मोडिफिकेशन करने के लिए बोला गया है आपको
लगता है कुछ मोडिफिकेशन होना चाहिए तो
आपने बोला की चलो भैया आपको भी आता है तो
आप उसे कोड में मोडिफिकेशन कर दीजिए आपने
टीम मेंबर को बोला अब भाई आपने उसमें
कमेंट किया है तो आपने बताया नहीं की यह
लॉजिक किस परपज से लगाया है इसका क्या
मतलब है मैं क्यों लगाया इतना छह रहा था
मैं क्या समझना चाहता हूं या क्या कोड
परफॉर्म करना चाहता हूं क्या तास परफॉर्म
करना चाहता हूं यहां पर अगर आपने वो कमेंट
वहां पर उसे किया है तो आपका जो टीम है
उसको उसे कोड को समझना में बहुत टाइम
वेस्ट हो जाएगा समझ लगा लेकिन उसको बहुत
टाइम वेस्ट हो जाएगा अगर कमेंटिंग की होगी
आपने उसको अच्छे अच्छे से उसको कमेंट किया
होगा तो क्या होगा क्योंकि तुरंत जल्दी से
समझ पाया और उसके बाद उसके हिसाब से
मोडिफिकेशन या उसमें रीजन रेट करना और कुछ
नया क्रिएशन करना है कुछ एड करना है कुछ
रिमूव करना हो आसानी से कर पाएगा ये है
बेसिक परपज है कमेंटिंग का तो समझ में
आएगा अब आप कमेंट कैसे करते हो आपको कमेंट
करने के लिए आप क्या उसे करते हो
आप उसे करते हो आप कमेंट करने के लिए इसका
क्या कर दे इसका उसे करते हो
कमेंट करने के लिए उसके बाद में कुछ भी
लिख देते हैं पर एग्जांपल कैसे लिखा जाता
है मैं आपको इधर बता देता हूं हज उसके बाद
दिस इसे मी
लिख दिया अब क्या है
जब भी आपका जो सेल है बेस्ट सेल है आपकी
प्रोग्राम को क्या करता है जो एग्जीक्यूट
करता है
तो आपका सेल क्या समझना है जब भी ये
करैक्टर देखा आपके सेल को देख रहा हूं जब
ये लाइन देखने को मिलती है हज हज साइन के
साथ पॉर्न साइन के साथ तो क्या करता है
आपका जो सेल समझ जाता है की भैया मुझे
इसको एग्जीक्यूट ऐसे मुझे पढ़ना नहीं है
इसको मुझे क्या कहना स्किप करना है
क्योंकि ये मेरे लिए नहीं है ये यूजर के
लिए है मुझे इससे कोई मतलब नहीं है सेल्स
को समझना है तो ये था कमेंट के बड़े में
और परपज हम कमेंट का आपको पता चल गया अब
मैं आपको सीखना हूं की आप अपने स्क्रिप्ट
को एक प्रोफेशनल वे में कैसे लिख सकते हो
तो वह प्रोफेशन में ले में लिखने के लिए
आपके पास क्या है कुछ पीसी जो इनफॉरमेशन
मेंशन करनी पड़ती है
वही प्रोफेशनल लुक में
यहां किसी एक बांदा है और प्रोफेशनल स्किप
को प्रोग्राम किया है स्क्रिप्ट को लिखा
है
वैसा करने के लिए फिर एक काम नेक्स्ट लाइन
में चला हूं
ओके
भाई पीसीएस ऑफ इनफॉरमेशन
वे उसे तू मेक अवर स्क्रिप्ट
प्रोफेशनल
इनफॉरमेशन कौन सी है फर्स्ट
जो फर्स्ट
है
शिफ्टिंग के दौरान
चीज आपको अच्छे से बेहतर तरीके से समझ
ले प्रैक्टिकल एग्जांपल लेक ए रहा हूं एक
प्रैक्टिकल एग्जांपल क्या है की मैं
स्क्रिप्ट क्रिएट करके दिखाऊंगा आपके
सामने और प्रोफेशनली कैसे उसको आप केयर कर
सकते हो प्रोफेशनली कैसे देखेगी इन साड़ी
चीजों के साथ में जस्ट एक छोटी सी कृपया
आपके सामने ट्रेड करने वाला हूं उसके बाद
हम अपने टॉपिक पर चलेंगे तो अब वो
एग्जांपल क्या है ये जो हमें एग्जांपल
क्रिएट करना है
ये रहा
एग्जांपल
जो डी
फाइल्स इन योर होम डायरेक्टरी
योर होम डायरेक्टर
करनी है
कंसीडर
थिस
स्क्रिप्ट
बिल बी
डी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
स्क्रिप्ट इस
प्रोफेशनल
प्रोफेशनली फॉर्मेटिव प्रोफेशनल फॉर्मेटिव
बिफोर
चीज
करनी है
वो क्रिएट होना चाहिए दूसरा आपको क्या
रखना है ध्यान में दोस्तों आपको ध्यान में
रखना की आपको ये भी कंसीडर करना है की
डिस्क्रिप्शन ये जो स्क्रिप्ट है
यह फूलों दूसरे लोगों के लिए जस्ट आपके
लिए नहीं हनी चाहिए दूसरे लोगों के लिए
प्रोफेशनल फॉर्मेटेड
मतलब आपको साड़ी चीजों को देखना है की जो
आपके
मतलब हनी चाहिए इसके लिए तो ये साड़ी
तीन-चार चीज चलो
काम करते हैं कैसे स्क्रिप्ट काम क्रिएट
कर सकते हैं ओके तो हम क्या करते हैं अपनी
स्क्रीन पर चलते हैं टर्मिनल पर मैं उसे
कर रहा हूं आप कोई भी उसे कर सकते हो 12
लाइनेक्स में कोई उसे कर सकते हैं मेरे
क्या है
उसमें थोड़ी सी प्रॉब्लम चल रही है अब
हमने क्या है
हमने क्या किया मैं सीडी करता हूं और
बेस्ट प्रैक्टिस के अंदर चला जाता हूं
बेस्ट प्रैक्टिस के अंदर चला जाऊंगा
क्रिएट करता हूं मैं क्या करता हूं नो नो
सेंड का उसे करने वाला हूं लेकिन मैं नैनो
उसे करने वाला हूं एडिटर का उसे करने वाला
है उसके बाद मैं क्या करता हूं बैकअप ई के
यू बैकअप उसके बाद स्क्रिप्ट
डॉट ऐसेट अगर नहीं भी लगाऊं तब भी काम
चलाया मैं आपके यहां डॉट असेट्स नहीं लगा
रहा नैनो ओपन किया आप आप सबको पता है की
सबसे पहले लाइन कौन सी होती है जो हम उसे
करते हैं यह बैंक पार्ट आप लोग कल बताया
था सबसे पहले हम पार्टी उसे करेंगे उसके
बाद
लेस्बियन लेस्बियन
लाइन को मैसेज कर दिया नेक्स्ट हमने क्या
करते हैं थोड़ा सा अच्छा लगे हमने सबसे
पहले हम अपना लुक देना है तो मैंने क्या
बताया था की जब भी हम कमेंटिंग अच्छे से
करेंगे कमेंटिंग अच्छे करने के लिए मैंने
क्या है कुछ पांच पीस ऑफ इनफॉरमेशन आपको
करने के लिए बोला था जो आपको काफी अच्छे
से ध्यान रखना चाहिए आपके लिए प्रोफेशनल
के लिए अगर आप चाहे तो अपने स्क्रिप्ट को
ऐसे लिख सकते हो विदाउट कमेंट भी लिख सकते
हो बट क्या है की उसमें कुछ टाइम के बाद
खुद ही कंफ्यूज हो जाओगे स्क्रिप्ट मैंने
किस परपज से लेकर का क्या मतलब था अब मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं सबसे पहले मैं कमेंट कर
रहा हूं मैं लिख रहा हूं की ऑथर कौन है
सबसे पहले ए यू टी हा ओ आर ऑथर प्रोफेशनल
स्क्रिप्ट
उसके बाद में क्या का रहा हूं उसके बाद
फिर मैं कमेंट कर रहा हूं अगर डेट
डेट
क्रीटेड है उसके बाद मैं क्या कर रहा हूं
अक्टूबर
[संगीत]
लास्ट मॉडिफाइड आज की डेट रहेगी मैंने
क्या कर दिया फर्स्ट अक्टूबर
पी आर ओ जे ए सिटी जब बेस्ट प्रोजेक्ट के
अंदर मैंने बेस्ट प्रोजेक्ट के अंदर जितने
भी फाइल है ना बैकअप ऑफ स्लैश बेस्ट
प्रोजेक्ट
ऑफ इंग्लिश
बेस्ट प्रोजेक्ट इसके अंदर जितने भी आप
प्रोजेक्ट कर रहे हो जो भी स्क्रिप्ट कर
रहे हो उसके साड़ी फाइल्स का बैकअप आप
अपनी होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर क्या कर रहे
हो आप अपनी
होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर क्या करना चाहते
हो बैक करना चाहते हो चलो नेक्स्ट मैंने
क्या किया था अब यूजेस यूजेस क्या करने
वाला हूं मैं यूजेस में
कमेंट कर रहा हूं
मैं बैकअप स्किप
बैक के अप बैकअप
स्क्रिप्ट बैकअप स्किप
देना
सिंपल है अब मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं देखो
आप एक चीज ध्यान में रखिए जब भी आपको
बैकअप जैसी चीज करनी पड़ती है तब क्या है
डायरेक्टली से तो फाइल का ऐसे बैकअप बनोगे
नहीं इसलिए आप क्या करो उसको कंप्रेस
करोगे
ओके मेरे पास एक ही कमांड में सर काम हो
जाएगा मैंने क्या किया तार करूंगा मैं तार
कमांड का उसे करूंगा बैकअप करने के लिए
हिफिन सीपीएफ रेट पर बस और फाइल अब मैं
इसका बैकअप बनाना चाहता हूं ओम डायरेक्टर
के अंदर कौन सा है
बेस्ट
फ्रेंड
नहीं बैकअप उसके बाद में कर लो साइन अब यह
चिंता करने की जरूर नहीं की मैंने क्या
उसे किया इसको कमांड सब्सीट्यूशन बोलते
हैं
उसके बाद प्लस उसके बाद परसेंटेज उसके बाद
मैं का रहा हूं दी एस परसेंटेज
ए उसके बाद अंडरस्कोर दिया मैंने उसके बाद
क्या किया परसेंटेज हा डी परसेंटेज एम एस
परसेंटेज
मेरे को डॉट तार रखना पड़ेगा डॉट तार
एक्सटेंशन मैं रखूंगा उसके बाद इसके अंदर
मेरी होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर उसके बाद जो
सभी की सभी जो मैंने स्टार मतलब जो
तू ग्रेटर दें सिंबल दें उसके बाद
मैं का देता हूं
जो और लाइन थी उसको मैं एग्जिट जीरो
कर देते हैं इसको
कंट्रोल
एक चीज समझना अभी
जब मैंने क्या बोला था आपको जो कंडीशन
क्या थी हम इसको रन करेंगे लेकिन कंडीशन
क्या थी मुकुंद को समझा दो उसके अंदर मैं
बता दूंगा
आसानी से बैकअप कर पे जो फाइल्स और होम
डायरेक्टरी ओके होम डायरेक्टर के अंदर
दोस्तों आपको ये भी कंसीडर करना है की वो
आपके ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के बाकी लोगों के लिए
यूजफुल हनी चाहिए और आपको ये मेक सर करना
है की स्क्रिप्ट प्रोफेशनल फॉर्मेटेड होने
चाहिए बिफोर सेलिंग आईटी ओके अब एक बात
बताओ आपको फॉर्मेटेड करनी है प्रोफेशनली
फॉर्मेटेड हो रही है वो होगी उसके अंदर
आपने कमेंट्स को उसे कर लिया नेक्स्ट आपको
क्या करना है ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में दूसरे
लोगों के साथ भी शेर करना है जब इस चीज को
आपको ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में दूसरे लोगों को साथ
शेर करना होगा तो आपको क्या चीज ध्यान
रखना होगी आपको सबसे पहले चीज तो उसकी
परमीशंस के बड़े में ध्यान रखना होगा
क्योंकि जब भी आप किसी के साथ स्किप को
शेर करोगे तो आपको उसकी परमीशंस के बड़े
में ध्यान में रखना होगा तो परमेश्वर के
बड़े में ध्यान में कैसे रहोगे तो सिंपली
आपको है
परमीशंस क्या रहेंगे उसके ऊपर परमीशंस
क्या रहेंगे
[संगीत]
ओके सॉरी पर डिस्टरबेंस तो परमीशंस क्या
रहेंगे मुझे क्या चीज है प्रोफेशनली है
ऊपर से ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में दूसरे लोगों के
साथ शेर भी करना है और आपकी टीम मेंबर्स
के तो सब सबसे पहले चीज आपको ध्यान में
क्या रखना है कोई भी स्क्रिप्ट आपके एड
करते हो सबसे पहले आपको ध्यान में रखना
क्योंकि परमीशंस क्या रहेंगे परमिशन फाइल
होना जो फाइल होना है फाइल ओनर की क्या
परमिशन नहीं आपको बता देता हूं फाइल ओनर
के लिए परमिशन नाम क्या रखेंगे देखो
जो फाइल ओनर है उसके लिए आप परमिशन क्या
रखोगे
रीड
राइट और तीनों परमिशन
आप ही हो आपने इसको क्रिएट किया है तो आप
इसके लिए परमिशन कौन सी डिफाइन करोगे डेड
एग्जीक्यूशन होगी उसके बाद जो ग्रुप
मेंबर्स आएंगे जो टीम मेंबर्स आएंगे टीम
मेंबर्स बेसिकली क्या होंगे अगर आप एक ही
प्रोजेक्ट पर काम कर रहे होंगे तो आपके
टीम मेंबर्स आपके ग्रुप ग्रुप मेंबर होंगे
वो आपका ग्रुप का पार्ट है तो अब जो ग्रुप
है उनको क्या परमिशन डॉग ग्रुप को आपको
परमिशन कौन सी देनी होगी आपको बेसिकली
रीड और उसके बाद एग्जीक्यूट परमिशन देनी
होगी राइट परमिशन आप नहीं डॉग ग्रुप में
टीम मेंबर्स को क्योंकि ओके ठीक है आपने
अपनी टीम मेंबर्स के लिए
आपने एक ऐसी स्क्रिप्ट पीरियड की है की
उनका काम उसे हो जाएगा बट आप बस आपको क्या
करना है उनको राइट परमिशन नहीं देना है
ताकि वो उसके साथ चेंज ना कर पे हो सकता
है किसी को आपसे कोई प्रॉब्लम हो वो आपके
स्क्रिप्ट को चेंज करके उसके बाद
क्या-क्या नाम खराब हो जाए नेक्स्ट जो बात
आई है आपकी वो है
जो आदर्श ए गया उनको क्या है परमिशन डॉग
परमिशन देनी होगी ना आदर्श को आप क्या
करोगे रीड ओनली रीड ओनली इनफॉरमेशन दो
क्यों क्योंकि भैया
और भी लोग काम करते हैं हो सकता है की इस
से लोकल एरिया में जिसमें आपका सर्वर है
इस पे आपका रिमोट एक्सेस है हो सकता है और
भी कोई काम करें तो जो आदर्श यूजर्स हैं
अगर वो उनके पास स्क्रिप्ट एक्सेस मिली भी
जाता हूं ओनली वो क्या कर पे इसको रेड कर
आए एग्जीक्यूट ना कर पे ना आए उसको
मॉडिफाई की तो बहुत ही छोड़ो क्योंकि रेड
परमिशन है नहीं तो ये परमिशन आपको देनी
पड़ेगी क्योंकि आपने पहले चीज सोची की
आपको बैकअप करना है दूसरा ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के
लोगो के बड़े में सोचा तीसरा आपको क्या
करना है की अब ये चीज भी तो प्रोफेशनल काम
करते हैं ना प्रोफेशनली हनी चाहिए ना ऐसा
नहीं है की आपने ओके सारे काम सब कुछ सही
किया है लेकिन क्या किया आपने उसकी परमिशन
से रिलेटेड उसकी सिक्योरिटी से रिलेटेड जो
चीज हैं उनको भी ध्यान नहीं दिया तो एक
बार बताइए प्रोफेशनल फॉर्मेट तो हो ही
नहीं तो वही चीज अब हम यहां पर देखेंगे तो
मैंने क्या करना है इसको परमिशन के लिए क
मोड उसके बाद मैं क्या करूंगा सेवन उसके
बाद 5 या 47 मतलब
रीड और एग्जीक्यूट फोर मतलब रीड ओनली
बैकअप
उसके बाद स्किप
में इसको क्या करता हूं अब मैं इसको क्या
करता हूं जब भी मैं रन करता हूं अभी मैं
इसका कर दूंगा
[संगीत]
बैकअप स्किप
कर दिया और मैं
ओके
देखो एक बार फिर से मैं स्किप करण करता था
जिसके अंदर मैं क्या करना चाहता हूं
इसको क्या करना चाहता हूं बैकअप करना
चाहता हूं ओके जिसके अंदर और किस लोकेशन
में उसको बैकअप करना चाहता हूं फूल वहां
पे यहां पर क्या बैकअप करना चाहता हूं और
इसका इसके अंदर रूट होम डायरेक्टर के अंदर
जितने भी जो फाइल्स हैं वो सारे के सारे
क्या कहना चाहता हूं बैकअप करना था इसके
अंदर उल्टा लिख दिया मैंने होम की साड़ी
फाइलों बैकअप करना चाहता हूं इसके अंदर ये
सी ग्रेट बैकअप इन लिखना ओके रीड इंपैक्ट
का इन ओके ओके चलो
जो फाइल्स ऑफ डी होम डायरेक्टरी
ऑफ डी होम
चीज है मुझे तो बार-बार इसको क्या करना है
अब मैंने फिर से एक बार किया गया है
लेकिन क्या है
की आपको ये चीज याद रखना की जरूर भी नहीं
है ये ऑटोमेटेकली उसे टाइम के ऊपर उसे
ड्यूल टाइम के साथ उसको क्या कर देगा
बट क्या ये अभी मैंने प्रोजेक्ट में थोड़ा
सा यहां पर कंफ्यूज ना हो इसलिए मैं यहां
पर लिख देता हूं यहां पर
मैं कैसे की डेट यू कैन उसे तू इसलिए
बैकअप जो डी फाइल्स इन योर होम डायरेक्टरी
पाइल्स ऑफ
फाइल्स का योर होम डायरेक्टरी
मेक ए गिफ्ट
समझ में ए गया होगा की दो चीज मैंने बता
दिया कमेंटिंग कैसे करते हैं उसके बाद
मैंने बताया की
प्रोफेशनल स्किप चीजों को एड किया है कैसे
उसको कमेंटिंग करना है उसके बाद मैंने
एग्जांपल लिया है छोटे से स्किप
को क्रिएट करना है एक बार दिखा देता हूं
अगर आपको नैनो करके दिखाऊं तो ये रहा ये
उसके सारे प्रोफेशनल लुक दिया मैंने यहां
पर तार कमांड का उसे किया जाता है तार बोल
के एड करने के लिए कंप्रेस करने के लिए
हाय फांसी की रेड करने के लिए मतलब बस
फाइल ये वो बात मेंशन करना जहां पर बैकअप
मार रहे हो और यहां पर मतलब क्या है ये
सारे के सारे होम डायरेक्टर
साहब हैं कर फाइल में जाके यहां पे स्टोर
हो जाएगा उसके बाद तू ग्रेटर फाइल क्यों
दी है मैं ऑलरेडी अपनी क्लास में आपको
पहले बता सुकून इसको मैंने क्यों दिया हुआ
है क्योंकि अगर कोई एरर आई है तो एरर क्या
होता है
की आप बोलोगे सर ये क्या चीज
इसके अंदर ये रहा इसके अंदर जो आप जो भी
कुछ लिखोगे वो आगे ए कमांड है काम करेगा
उसे कमांड एग्जीक्यूटिव उसका आउटपुट आगे
यहां पर स्टोर हो जाएगा इसकी जगह पर उनके
अंदर डबल को के अंदर ये है कमांडर आने
वाले क्लासेस में अच्छे से डिटेल में सबको
समझाऊंगा तो आई होप मुझे बस यस या नो
बताइए अभी तक जो मैंने आज अभी तक जो बताया
है
सभी को अभी तक क्लियर है या नहीं है
यस या नो
इट्स ओके तो नेक्स्ट टॉपिक जो हमारा ए
चुका है मैक्सिमम अभी और काफी इंटरेस्टिंग
टॉपिक हमेशा पढ़ना वाला हूं आपको एक बार
नीचे चलते हैं
अब जो मैं पढ़ना वाला हूं ना काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग ऑफ इंटरेस्टिंग है मतलब और
काफी जरूरी भी है अगर वह आपको नहीं पता
था
कुछ प्रॉब्लम
मैंने किया इसको
मैं आपको सीखना हूं
ओके बेस्ट ऑनलाइन
अभी तक आपने क्या शिखा देखो अभी तक मैंने
आपको क्या शिखा है जो शिवा बैंक लाइन है
शिवा बैंक लाइन में आप क्या करते हो
इंटरप्रेटर को मेंशन करते हो ओके आप क्या
करते हो इंटरप्रेटर का मेंशन करते हो जब
भी आप क्या करते हो एक स्किप को रन करते
हो तो बेस्ट क्या करता है आपकी स्क्रिप्ट
को क्या करता है लाइन बाय लाइन रीड करता
है
उसके बाद क्या होता है की हर एक लाइन के
लिए बेस्ट क्या करता है फाइव स्टेप
प्रोसेस होता है एक फाइव स्टेप प्रोसेस
होता है उसको फॉलो करता है आपकी कमांड्स
को इंटरप्रेट करने के लिए मैं यहां पर लिख
देता हूं
मैं यहां पर एप्लीकेशन
डी कमांड
इस के बाद क्या होता है
उसको फॉलो करता है
उसके बाद ही डिसाइड करता है की इस लाइन के
साथ मुझे करना क्या है एग्जिट करना है
नहीं करना है एरर देना है या इसका आउटपुट
मुझे क्या परफॉर्म करना है
उसके लिए काफी ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है
आपको नहीं आई अगर आपको बेस्ट जो है उसके
अंदर जो कमांड है वह कैसे प्रोसेस करते
हैं
ऐसे नहीं करती अगर उसके बड़े में आपको
उसकी कोई नॉलेज नहीं है तो आपके लिए बेस्ट
गिफ्ट
जब तक आपको यह नहीं पता की भैंस के अंदर
जो कमांड है वह कैसे प्रोसेस करती है
लाइन जब भी उसको एक लाइन है कोई भी सिंगल
कैसे प्रोसेस करती है जब तक आपको ये चीज
नहीं पता तो उससे तब तक आपको क्या बग्स और
एरर्स देखने को मिलते हैं गिफ्ट के अंदर
जिसकी वजह से आपको इस नॉलेज के इस नॉलेज
की कमी के करण आपको क्या है आपके
स्क्रिप्ट में बहुत सारे बॉक्स और के साथ
प्रॉब्लम फेस करनी पड़ती है और आप क्या की
गूगल करते रहते हो यह करते रहते हैं की
मैं करने की तो कोशिश यह कर रहा हूं बट ये
टास्क में परफॉर्म नहीं हो का रहा है
क्यों ए रही है उसके बाद गूगल करते हो कुछ
फोंट पढ़ने हो उसको लॉजिक को लगाते हो फिर
भी आपको एक्जेक्टली पता नहीं राहत की यह
काम कैसे कर रही है दिस इसे डी प्रॉब्लम
अगर आपको यह प्रोसेस नहीं पता तो कोई
फायदा नहीं है उसके बाद जब ये पांच स्टेप
प्रोसेस हो जाति है जो फाइव स्टेप प्रोसेस
है
उसके बाद उसे कमांड लाइन को क्या किया
जाता है एग्जीक्यूट किया जाता है अब ये
पांच प्रोसेस होते क्या है ये फाइव
स्टेप्स कौन-कौन से होते हैं
स्टेप्स है वह बताता हूं
जो फर्स्ट है जिसको हम बोलते हैं
कमांड आईडेंटिफिकेशन
[संगीत]
गो थ्रू करती है जाति है उसके बाद
एग्जीक्यूट करती है
ना
तो अभी
वन बाय वन सभी के बड़े में सीखेंगे
सेल एक्सपेंशन के बड़े में कोर्ट के
डायरेक्शन सभी के बड़े में हम वन बाय वन
हम क्या करेंगे पढ़ेंगे तो अब यह बताइए की
आपको मैं फरदर आगे पढ़ना या कल करना पसंद
करोगे नेक्स्ट
बताइए
ओके बढ़ाओ एक एक और और कोई कंटिन्यू और
उठाना चाहिए ना यस नो यस नो
कंटिन्यू करें
[संगीत]
मुझे लगता है की ओके
चलो फिर हम कंटिन्यू करते हैं ओके
[संगीत]
नेक्स्ट क्लास
ठीक
है
जल्दी नहीं है
और ऊपर से भी ना जाए
उनको लगता की काफी लोग हो गया
आराम से
टाइम लगेगा
ऐसे क्लियर नहीं होंगे और ये पांचो स्टेप
को आपको समझना बहुत ही ज्यादा जरूरी है
अगर यह पांच स्टेप आपको नहीं समझ में आया
तो आपको ये यूजलेस हो जाएगा इसलिए बोल रहा
हूं की जो कंटिन्यू ए रहे हैं डोंट स्किप
करना है तो ओके
ऐसे करना है
जिसको जो पूछना पूछ सकते हैं अभी तक
अग्रवाल अग्रवाल
[संगीत]
बेसिकली कहना की आप कहानी भी उसे करते हो
हर जगह मतलब की आप लाइनेक्स एडमिन हो तब
भी आपका बेस्ट काम आई है
सिक्योरिटी में क्या कर रहे हो एवं हैकिंग
टास्क परफॉर्म कर रहे होते हो तो
स्टार्टिंग फॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग के उनमें
क्या करते हैं आपके क्या है बेसिकली आप
लोग टूल उसे करते हो ना जब भी आपको ये टूल
उसे करते तो कितनी बार है आज करवाते उसके
फ्लैग ये आज नहीं कर पाते यार कुछ चीज
आपके पास याद नहीं रहती आपको बार-बार क्या
नोट्स को फॉलो करना पड़ता है अब बार-बार
आप नोट्स को फॉलो करोगे तो अब प्रॉब्लम है
ना भैया तो इससे बढ़िया है की अगर आपको
सेल्फ स्क्रिप्ट आई है आपको पता है की
मुझे क्या-क्या काम करनी है पर एग्जांपल
मैं आपको बताता हूं की आपके पास तीन टूल
है तीन टूल आपके क्या डोमेन एनीमेशन किया
है आपने डोमेन डोमेन सब डोमेन फाइंड आउट
करने के लिए ठीक है तीन टूल को उसे करते
हो उसके बाद क्या करते हो आप तीन टूल के
बाद आप क्या करते हो की उनमें से लाइव
निकलते हो और दादा वाले आउट करते हो उसके
लिए कुछ कमांड और कुछ कटिंग का काम करते
हो उसके बाद क्या की उसमें भी रिपीटेड हो
जाते हैं फिर उसके बाद आप यूनिक डोमेन
निकलते हैं उसमें यूनिक मतलब की शॉर्ट
करते हो उसको शॉट करने के लिए भी कमांड
उसे करते हो दें उसके बाद क्या है की मेरे
को टूल परफॉर्म करते हैं की उसमें लाइव है
या अलाइव है उसके स्क्रीनशॉट लेते हुए
साड़ी चीजें टास्क स्टेप बाय स्टेप
परफॉर्म करते हो तो आप ऐसा क्या कर सकते
हो की अगर आप लेजी हो और आपको लगता की यार
बार-बार मैं साड़ी चीज नहीं कर सकता आप
क्या कर सकते क्योंकि हम सारे काम तो
लिरिक्स में कर रहे हो ना आपको फ्लैग याद
है कमांड याद है टास्क कैसे परफॉर्म करना
है तो वो वो सारे स्टेप आप अपने एक
स्क्रिप्ट खुद से स्क्रिप्ट बना सकते हो
की आईएफ ऐसा हुआ तो यह करना होगा अगर
अच्छा ऐसा नहीं होता ये करना होगा बस एक
बार आपकी मेहनत लगी है आपको स्क्रिप्टिंग
आई है अपने एक दिन स्पेंड कर लिया दो दिन
स्पेंड के लिए तीन दिन स्पेंड के लिए उसके
बाद नेक्स्ट टाइम आपने क्या की खुद की
सेल्स बेस्ट गिफ्ट बना ली तो आप क्या
करोगे सिंपली आपको क्या की उसके उसमें
स्किप के नाम के साथ क्या मेंशन करना होगा
उसका जो नाम है एग्जांपल
देना है आईपीएल दाल देना जो भी देना है बस
वो मेंशन करना तो वह 5 से 6 तक आपको सब एक
इंटर करना उसके बाद आपको वेट करना है चाय
पी लो कॉफी पी लो वॅटीवर जितना टाइम लगे
वाला आपका कमांड अपना काम करता रहेगा इसके
आपका काम होता रहेगा और आपको कुछ नहीं
करना बस ऑटोमेशन का तास परफॉर्म होगा सबसे
बड़ा एक रीजन ये हो जाता है इसमें और भी
जैसे की कुछ आप मल्टीप्लेक्स प्रोजेक्ट्स
पे काम कर रहे हो तो पर एग्जांपल आप
पायदान के साथ प्रोजेक्ट पे काम कर रहे
होंगे सॉकेट प्रोग्रामिंग की सही
प्रोग्रामिंग की उसके बाद क्या है की आप
फाइनली आपको नेक्स्ट पे आना ही पड़ता है
तो नेक्स्ट पे फिर टास्क फिर भी परफॉर्म
करना पड़ेगा तो तब भी आपको क्या करना है
जरूर पड़ेगी बेस्ट को उसे करना है और कोई
किसी ने पूछा था की बेसिकली सेल और बेस्ट
स्किपिंग में इतना ज्यादा अंतर नहीं है
भैया देखो अब ये क्या है की यहां सेल पे
काम करती है बट क्या है की कुछ लोग
लेकिन बेस्ट शूटिंग के बेस्ट के स्पेसिफिक
है ये और सेल में क्या है की कुछ ऐसी जो
है जो कोमल सब पे काम करती है बट क्या है
की लोगों ने इसको क्या अलग-अलग नाम दे रखा
है की एक सेल है एक बेस है बट इतना ज्यादा
डिफरेंस नहीं है बस लेते हैं डिफरेंस है
ये एक स्पेशली पर बेस्ट एक सेल के स्पेशली
सेल जिसमें की आएगी वो सब पे ही काम करें
बट क्या है की इतना
भी डिफरेंस नहीं है वही आईएफ कंडीशन
स्टेटमेंट है सब कुछ वही है इतना ज्यादा
कोई डिफरेंस नहीं अगर आप किसी भी सेल पे
मैंने इसको परफॉर्म करो वो काम करता है बट
क्या इस लेस्बियंस इंटरप्रेटर इसलिए आप
मेंशन करते हो क्योंकि
बाकी जो सेल है आपके जो ऐसे सेल है उससे
क्या है की थोड़ा सा एक एडवांस फीचर के
साथ यह बहस काम करता हूं और बेस्ट सबके
साथ ही बेस्ट सबके साथ ही क्या कर रहा है
की काम करता है हार्ले नेक्स्ट में इसलिए
क्या है की हम इस स्पेशली इंटरप्रेटर
मैनेजमेंट करते हैं बेस्ट मैंने आपको अगर
कल की क्लास आपने अच्छी नहीं तो कल मैंने
आपको स्पेशली बताया था की हम इंटरप्रेटर
क्यों मेंशन करते हैं ओके तो ये चीज है और
आपका आंसर वैसे मिल भी गया होगा बस की
डिफरेंस बताओ थोड़ा सा ज्यादा डिफरेंस
नहीं होता है बाकी और क्या था
वैसे भी काली को उसे कर सकते हो
आप की कैपेबिलिटी पर डिपेंड करता है की आप
उसे ऑटोमेशन में कितने टूल्स को आप मतलब
की आप कितना लॉजिक लगा सकते हो जितने
लॉजिक आप किसी भी प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज
में लगा सकते हो उतना ज्यादा आपके
प्रोग्राम को बटर कर सकते हो क्योंकि
प्रोग्रामिंग में पूरा खेल
उतना ही आप अच्छा कोड लिख सकते हो अगर
आपके पास लॉजिक नहीं है तो
यूजलेस सब कुछ
तो और कोई किसी का स्टील को डाउट
किया के 2 3 लोगों ने यह सवाल मुझे पूछा
है इससे ज्यादा तो कुछ नहीं
है जो स्टार्टिंग
करेंगे मिनिमम तो मुझे जो आज जो मिनिमम
स्टैंडर्ड है ये जो क्लास का जो स्टैंडर्ड
है मिनिमम 700 व्यू है तो वो तो होना ही
होना चाहिए अदर वाइस क्या है की फिर इससे
नीचे मैं आई कैन'टी दो एनीथिंग अगर इसी
नीचे अगर आप लेक ए जाओगे कल मैं डे तू पे
सिक्स हंड्रेड
भी लगा के रख देंगे ऐसा है तो भूल जाइए
हमें भी क आउट करने के लिए आपके काफी
मेहनत करनी पड़ती है और इतना भी नहीं कर
सकते हो
इसकी कमांड आई है बेसिकली बेस्ट क्या आपके
ओनली लेग्स के लिए ऐसा नहीं की आप जाकर की
विंडो में बेस्ट स्क्रिप्टिंग कर डॉग नहीं
कर सकते मैसेज स्पेसिफिक ओनली फोर लेंस
नोट पर विंडोज ओनली
ओके
लेंस के साथ कुछ भी कर सकते हो बेसिकली
प्रोग्रामिंग है ये एक प्रकार से
बोल सकते हो इससे ज्यादा और कुछ नहीं है
मुझे हां एक चीज है
अभी तक
मुझे लगता है की मैंने जो कंस्ट्रक्ट
पटाया है अभी तक आपके सामने मैंने एक छोटा
सा प्रोजेक्ट क्रिएट किया है प्रोजेक्ट के
साथ मैंने उसको एग्जीक्यूट भी करवाया है
तो मुझे आप लोगों से एक उम्मीद है की आपके
दिमाग में क्वेश्चन आना चाहिए था
इसलिए मैंने उसको खुद से इसलिए नहीं बताया
इसलिए मैंने खुद से नहीं बताया क्योंकि
मैं
चाहता हूं की वह आपके दिमाग में और इससे
मुझे पता चलेगा की नहीं आप लोग कितने
एक्टिव हो कितने नहीं और कितना आपका दिमाग
काम करता है क्योंकि वह क्वेश्चंस का आंसर
मैं दे सकता था बट क्या की आई बिल वेट पर
डी नेक्स्ट क्लास की आप उसको सोच पाते हो
नहीं सोच पाते की वो क्या क्वेश्चन था की
जो हमसे पूछने वाले हैं ओके वो क्वेश्चन
डेफिनेटली में वेट कर रहा हूं और वो आना
चाहिए क्योंकि वो आप अगर स्क्रिप्ट लिखने
की सोच भी रहे हो और आप अभी तक आज तक इतने
टूल्स उसे किया हैं जिन्होंने तो वह
क्वेश्चन डेफिनेटली आपके मन में रहना
चाहिए तो मैं वेट कर रहा हूं की वो
क्वेश्चन आपके दिमाग में आना ही चाहिए ही
चाहिए अगर वो क्वेश्चन आपके दिमाग में
नहीं ए रहा तो तो चाहिए दोनों क्लास को एक
बार फिर से देखिए फिर वो क्वेश्चन सूजी को
क्या क्वेश्चन है जो मैं आप लोगों से
पूछने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं जिनको जिसको आप
लोगों को मुझे पूछना चाहिए बल्कि हर
क्वेश्चंस मुझे ये आपको आंसर नहीं करना
चाहिए ओके तो फिर नेक्स्ट क्लास में मिलते
हैं
बाय बाय